My first guest.
Of course, a talented actor who has starred
in numerous films including Rogue One: A Star Wars Story,
Milk, and Y Tu Mama Tambien.
Please welcome Mexico City's own Diego Luna!
(audience applauding)
(mariachi music)
Yes!
(audience applauding)
Thank you so much for being here.
Thank you for being here!
When we announced that we were coming to Mexico City,
you immediately said, "I'm in,"
and we're very grateful that you're a part of this.
No, I am very happy you're doing this.
This means all lot to all of us, obviously, you can see.
Yeah.
(audience applauding)
How do you think?
I mean, you saw that I tried to be in a telenova, so--
No, no, I was laughing out there,
I mean, it's ridiculous. You--
What's the problem? Que?
I'm sure that you've been getting a lot
of Mexican women's attention.
I can smell your urgency. It's a problem.
You think that's the problem with--
The Mexican women sense that I'm too needy,
is that it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
It's pretty obvious you're asking for--
What about this? Is this hurting me
or helping me in Mexico?
That's hurting you badly.
(Conan and audience laughing)
I'll tell you what, I mean, you're huge.
Clearly, you're huge.
Big guy, yeah.
You're the size of two Mexicans put together.
(Conan and audience laughing)
You're a guy, and there is a woman there,
and she's intimidated, you know?
Yes.
And you don't have to add another half a meter of hair.
(Conan and audience laughing)
It's so pretentious, like, "Oh, I have this--
Okay, okay.
"This is hard all day long.
Look at my hair."
So you think I could, if I change the hair
and I relax a little bit--
I think if, may I?
Yes, go ahead, go for it, go for it.
Oh, there you go. It moves!
This is magnificent.
Get in there, get in there, get in there.
Oh yeah!
I also have a--
Now I just look drunk.
Don't I look--
I'm gonna get you drunk.
Oh, what is this?
I brought the medicine for your urgency.
This is gonna make you chill.
That's a mezcal.
This is a mezcal, all right.
Sorry I didn't bring the big bottle,
but that's the size I use when I'm nervous
to go into your show,
Okay.
Or before the PTA meeting at the school of my kids.
(audience laughing)
Viva Mexico!
Viva Mexico City! Salud!
Now, I wanna ask you, Diego,
this is fascinating to me,
you got your start in telenovelas--
I did.
You began in telenovelas.
You actually had sex on film
before you had actual sex, is that true?
Yes, you're going too far.
(audience laughing)
No, it's true!
I did, I did, I did.
You probably, when you go like,
"When was the first I had sex?"
You have to remember, you go through this memory.
I can just rent a film, basically.
You know exactly when it happened?
Yes, I know exactly.
It was this amazing actress, beautiful,
and I was dreaming about it, and I felt the luckiest.
I was 12 years old.
12?
Yeah.
You had a sex scene when you were 12?
Oh, yeah.
(audience laughing)
But I arrived, and I was very nervous,
and I was just like, "Well, I hope she likes it then,
and after the scene,
because I know it's not gonna be sex,
but then something can start from there," right?
Yeah.
And then I get there,
and there I see 40 people looking at me with the camera.
They got the cameras, yeah, everything.
And I go like, "Shit!"
And I can just think of like,
"Ah, I don't wanna have a hard,
please, please, please, I don't wanna get too excited,"
you know, that kind of thing.
Yeah, yeah.
And obviously it didn't happen.
I was 12; I couldn't control it.
She was very nice.
She'd hide it.
She took good care of you, that's the important thing.
She took good care,
but I started doing telenovelas, you know, here.
Yeah, you started doing telenovelas.
It was your training, and then, of course,
what's happened to you
since then has been absolutely spectacular.
It has.
Rogue One: A Star Wars Story.
Significant. I mean, biggest film in the world,
and such a big deal for a Latino to be a lead
in a Star Wars movie.
This was a seismic change.
It meant a lot, and it meant a lot for,
I mean, today, in this time, this happening.
It's not a coincidence.
I read many things, and there was a beautiful thing
that a girl from San Diego wrote
about the experience of having her father watching the film,
and how the father reacted to my character and the accent,
and feeling represented on the screen.
So the father, of course, was Mexican?
The father was an immigrant, yeah.
An immigrant, and he saw, and he couldn't believe--
He couldn't believe it.
He was watching a Star Wars film,
and that his accent was represented,
that he knew who I was.
That's amazing.
(audience applauding)
Yeah, I mean, I think it's the kind
of medicine we're talking about in these times.
We need that medicine.
I have, obviously we're doing a lot of comedy here,
but on a personal level, I've talked to many,
many Mexicans since I arrived,
and this is the biggest feeling that I get from them.
They feel misunderstood, and their feelings are hurt
on a very simple, human level.
Specific politics aside, they've heard these things
that were said at campaign rallies,
they've heard this chant, "Build the wall,"
they've heard certain words used about them,
and I've spent a lot of time trying to explain to them
many people in the United States love the Mexican people.
This is a misrepresentation of how people feel.
Definitely.
And I think that needs to come across.
(audience applauding)
I agree, and I think those people
that are afraid of being deported today,
their voice has been silent,
and we have to make sure their stories are told
in and out of States,
and that they get their stories matter to us,
because they need that strength to keep going,
and ignorance, we can fight with love and with understanding
and with things like what you are doing, showing respect.
We've wanted this to be a very positive experience,
and what's the most beautiful thing for me is that--
You wanted sex, I mean, don't get us confused.
I mean, you came, and you ask a producer,
"Please, I want to have sex."
Listen, please. Okay, yes, okay.
That was clear.
Okay. Numero uno: sex, okay?
But numero dos was to bring positivity--
(Conan, Diego, and audience laughing)
Come on! Give me a break.
To the people of Mexico, and let them know
that we hear them, that they are heard,
and that what is so nice is that so many of them,
when they've had an opportunity to speak,
I don't get a lot of anger from them,
I get them talking in a very beautiful, eloquent way,
saying, "We need to come together. We're really--
It's about empathy, yeah.
It's empathy. Which makes me feel happy.
Well, I say we end on a positive note, which is we drink.
I am an optimist, and I think better times are coming,
so Viva Mexico!
Viva Mexico! Salud!
(audience applauding)
Rogue One: A Star Wars Story will be available
on Digital HD and Blu-ray on March 24th,
Diego Luna everybody!
Much more from Mexico when we return.
(audience cheering)